- [Kim] Hey this is Kim from Khan Academy
and today I'm learning about Article IV
of the U.S. Constitution.
Article IV lays out the nuts and bolts
of how federalism, the
system of shared governance
between the states and
the federal government
works in practice.
Article IV has four sections.
The first two,
the Full Faith and Credit clause
and the Privileges and Immunities clause
talk about how states will
treat each other's citizens
as well as they treat the
citizens of their own states.
Then the third section,
is an admissions clause
discussing how new states
will be added to the union
and the fourth section
is the guarantee clause,
which guarantees every state in the union
a republican form of government.
To learn more about Article IV,
I sought out the help of two experts.
Erin Hawley is an
associate professor of Law
at the University of Missouri.
Her scholarship focuses
on the federal courts
and she teaches constitutional litigation,
tax policy and agricultural law.
Professor Gabriel Chin is the
director of clinical legal
education at the UC Davis School of Law.
He's a teacher and scholar
of immigration law,
criminal procedure and race and law.
So professor Hawley can
take us a little bit
through why the framers
included Article IV.
What was its purpose?
- [Erin] The founders of the Constitution
were very concerned
that the federal government
be one of limited powers
and because of that they saw the states
as having an active and critical role
in placing a check on
the federal government.
So we've got the three
branches and their own checks
and balances and then we've
got the federal government
and the state government
also playing a role
in checking and balancing each other.
They wanted to establish a
strong central government
but also to ensure that it
didn't have too much power
and the states were
critical to this effort.
Also, they very much wanted
the states to act collectively
not individually.
As you'll recall,
the states had not been doing so well
under the loose articles
of the confederation.
They've sort of being going it
alone on critical issues like
trade and defense as to
the detriment of the union.
So Article IV is also a
sort of key to making sure
that the states act sort
of as a unified whole
rather than going it alone.
- [Gabriel] It's one country
made up of diverse states.
And if you prefer the way things are done
in Nevada
you can move there.
And if you think that some
other state has a better set of
answers to
the problems of modern life,
you can move.
What the Full Faith In Credit clause,
and the Privileges and Immunities clause
are designed to do is to facilitate
transactions, to facilitate moving,
to facilitate
communications and commerce
and trade and travel among the states.
But that doesn't mean that what's going on
in each of the states can't
be very, very different.
- [Kim] We often think of checks
and balances as being something
that was designed to
be kind of horizontal.
That the legislature
and the executive branch
and the judicial branch kind of all
at the same level checking each other.
But there is also kind of this
vertical checks and balances
happening too between the power
of the federal government,
power of the states and the
power of the local governments.
- [Erin] Absolutely so we've
got the three branches,
and their checks and balances.
We also have a strong central government,
that's checked in large part
by strong independent sovereign
governments in each of the 50 states.
And these states traditionally
have what are known
as police powers so they have
a lot of inherent authority
to govern the people in those states,
subject to federal law.
But it really does sort
of place a check on
federal authority and I
think this is precisely
what the framers wanted
because they did want
a strong government,
but they also were very
much of the view that
states were important.
That their own states we're important
and they didn't want to lose
that in the new constitution
and new federal government.
- [Kim] There are four
sections in Article IV
and the first section deals
with full faith and credit,
it says full faith and
credit shall be given
in each state to the public Acts, Records
and Judicial proceedings
of every other state.
So what does full faith
and credit actually mean?
- [Gabriel] It's designed
to make in a certain sense,
all of the states of the United States
part of a single system.
And so, full faith and credit means
that a court judgment
for example in one state
will be recognized in every state.
- [Erin] So if you have a value judgment
in New York for example,
and you move to California,
the California courts are
required to give effect to
that judgment, to that same court judgment
so long as it was validly issued.
There was a federal statue known as
The Defense of Marriage Act or DOMA
that was passed under president Clinton,
and recently the Supreme
Court struck that down
as unconstitutional.
So now under full faith and
credit, if you're married
in one state you're married
in another state as well.
- [Gabriel] You can see the kinds
of problems that would exist if
states didn't honor the
legal decision that were made
by other states such as who is married
or who is divorced
or who owns a particular piece of property
or whether a particular child
is going to be in the
custody of one parent
rather than another.
And the full faith and credit clause
is designed to say, in order for
our system to work
as a unified whole,
while it's true that the courts of Georgia
are distinct from the
courts of New York, etc.
They're separate systems,
but they have to treat the work
that each other does with respect.
- [Kim] If we move onto section II.
This says that the citizens of each state
shall be entitled to all
privileges and immunities
of citizens in the several states.
So what are these
privileges and immunities?
- [Erin] So the privileges
and immunities clause
has been one that's subject to a number of
sort of debates in the courts,
in the academic literature.
But basically privileges and immunities
have been construed to
be those sorts of things
that would go with citizenship.
So the right to travel for example,
is a privilege and immunity.
Those sorts of things.
- [Gabriel] Occasionally
in American history
there have been moments where states
didn't want to let citizens
of other states come through.
So during the depression there
was an effort by some states
to limit the migration
of people from out of state to in-state.
And the Supreme Court said,
that's not permissible.
It also protects the right to travel.
In 1999 the Supreme Court
dealt with a case called Saenz v. Roe.
And what that case was
about is that California
had relatively generous welfare benefits.
And California wanted to set up its law
in such a way that it
wouldn't encourage people
from other states to move to California
just to get the welfare benefits.
So what they did is,
they said that if you
don't live in California.
If you're moving from out of state
and you apply for welfare benefits
then we're going to give
you the welfare benefits
that you would have gotten in
your state for the first year.
We're not going to give you
the higher California benefits.
We're going to give you
whatever you would of gotten
where you came from.
That's unconstitutional
and the Supreme Court
said that violates the
privileges and immunities clause.
We're one country.
One nation.
People are allowed to cross
the borders whenever they want.
- [Kim] Interesting but there
is this second part of it
that says no person
held to service or labor
in one state, under the laws
thereof, escaping into another,
shall, in consequence, of
any law or regulation therein
be discharged from service or labor.
So what is that all about?
- [Erin] So that is one
of the most unfortunate,
probably the most unfortunate clauses
in our Constitution,
it's known as the fugitive slave clause
and that title is pretty descriptive.
So if you have a slave
who is validly owned
as it were in those days,
under one state's law
and that person escaped to a free state
this clause gave the owner the right to
reclaim that slave and put them back
into sort of ownership in their own state.
- [Gabriel] It is a sneaky
way of talking about slavery
and this compromise with
slavery was necessary to create
the United States.
Slavery, the word, isn't
used in the Constitution.
They only use these euphemisms.
These sort of complicated circumlocutions
and there is an argument that
there is a reason for that.
And the reason for that is
that a lot of the framers
of the Constitution
didn't support slavery.
Opposed slavery.
They did think that it
was important to have
a United States and to
have a Constitution.
So they wanted to do what
was necessary to achieve that
but they did the absolutely minimum
and they did it in such a way
that consciously doesn't recognize
and legitimize the institution of slavery.
- [Kim] Alright so, then we get into
new states and territories.
So, I think it was very forward looking
of the framers to
recognize that new states
might want to join the Union
and then to provide a process for that.
So can you tell us a little bit about
what that process was like?
- [Erin] So article IV
section three clause one
provides the process for
admitting new states.
Again it recognizes that
new states might want to
join the Union and it
gives wide latitude to
congress for admitting new states,
so basically the process
was that a territory
would indicate to the
congress that it wished
to become a state.
Then they would submit a constitution
and congress would approve the new state.
But the constitution
itself in article IV places
some limitations on that.
Some of the eastern states
we're concerned that the large
western territories might
become too influential
so they had a couple of provisions
that no new states could be
created out of an old state
nor could parts of states be
combined to form a new state
unless there was consent from
all of the involved states.
- [Gabriel] And it's not so
clear that purchase of territory
from foreign governments was a power that
was granted in the Constitution to anyone.
Thomas Jefferson who was
the president at the time
of the Louisiana Purchase had doubts
that the Louisiana Purchase
was constitutional.
He thought that it was
a great idea to purchase
all that land from France,
but he thought that it would
require a constitutional
amendment for the United
States to have that power.
This is different from
Texas joining the Union.
But the House and the
Senate didn't have the same
qualms that President Jefferson did.
And so they agreed to approve
the Louisiana Purchase
and to fund it.
When the bill got to Thomas
Jefferson's desk he signed.
- [Kim] Moving on to section IV,
there is this promise here
that the federal government
will guarantee every state a
republican form of government
and shall protect each
of them against invasion
or domestic violence.
What does this mean?
- [Erin] So we see here in
Article IV the end of Article IV
a really sort of famous, an
important promise to each
of the individual states.
The federal government is promising,
to basically aid them in keeping
a republican form of government.
As well remember, Benjamin Franklin
famously said we've given you
a republic if you can keep it.
- [Gabriel] So when we talk
about invasion in section IV,
it talks about invasion,
it's pretty clear that
what they're talking about
is invasion by some hostile state.
And of course during this period
there was continuing conflict with England
and the idea is that if New York
or South Carolina
gets invaded by England,
that's not just that particular
state's problem it's the nation's problem
and the national government
has an obligation
to protect against invasion.
- [Kim] I imagine it also
prevents someone from
for example declaring
themselves the King of Maryland.
- [Gabriel] The republican
form of government
clause does that.
It leaves the details to the states
but the basic idea is that there has,
the concept of republican
government that's embodied
in article IV is majority rule.
That even if there were
free and fair elections
the state could not
choose to have military
or hereditary government.
So even if everybody in
California got together,
and said you know,
what we really need is
a good family that
generation after generation
will lead us and they will be
the kings and queens of California,
and this is what we want so we're going to
amend our constitution
to provide for hereditary
leadership in our state
and we're going to find
somebody great and this
is what we want to do.
Article IV would say, we
can't choose to do that
even through democratic means.
- [Kim] So as we've learned Article IV
requires states to give
full faith and credit
to the legal proceedings
of other states and to treat the citizens
of other states as well as
they treat their own citizens.
It provides a process
for adding new states
into the mix and guarantees
a republican form
of government to the
citizens of all the states.
Article IV binds the
United States together
so it's not just a collection
of independent states
but rather a unified nation.
To learn more abour article IV
visit the National Constitution Centers
in Directive Constitution
and Khan Academy's resources
on U.S. government and politics.